(bright upbeat music)
- Hello, I'm Laura Sanders,
Senior Neuroscience
Writer at Science News.
And it's a big year here
for us at Science News.
It's our 100th anniversary
as an independent news
organization covering science.
And so to mark the occasion
we're talking with leaders
in the sciences on the big
questions in their field.
So I'm here with Sujata Gupta
our Social Science Writer
to talk about stress and resilience,
and how it affects our brains, our bodies,
and even our societies.
We're joined today by Dr. Huda Akil,
Professor of Neuroscience and Psychiatry,
and a member of the Michigan
Neuroscience Institute
at the University of
Michigan in Ann Arbor.
She studies both stress and
resilience in the brain,
and over her wide-ranging career,
she's discovered how stress in
our world affects our brains,
and she's also turned
up ways to counter it.
Dr. Akil thank you very much
for joining us.
- Thank you.
- And I'll now turn
to my fellow science news
writer, Sujata Gupta.
- Hi, as Laura said,
I'm Sujata Gupta a Social Sciences Writer,
and my guest today is Dr. Brendan Kohrt.
He's a Psychiatrist and Anthropologist
at George Washington University
and a global mental health expert
who has designed mental
health interventions
to help child soldiers
re-integrate into society in Nepal,
and programs to reduce the stigma
associated with mental illness
elsewhere in the world.
Dr. Kohrt thank you so
much for joining us.
- So, I'll turn to Dr. Akil first.
And I think, you know, this year,
this past two years, especially,
we've all heard people
say I'm so stressed out
and we all know what
that means intuitively,
but from your perspective, you know,
what does that mean from a
neuroscience point of view?
- Thank you, yeah, it's great to be here.
The stress system, stress is of course
a psychological concept
that we all experience
and it indicates a sense
of discomfort, alarm,
sometimes fear, anxiety,
uncertainty, and it carries
a lot of negative connotations.
It is also a piece of
biology that we share
with pretty much all mammals.
It's very clearly wired,
we have in our body
the ability to perceive the world,
and encode whether something
is going to be stressful or not.
And then there are
biochemical consequences
of this, where the encoding of an event
in the world around us, or even within us
says, pay attention, this is
threatening, this is important.
And then that information in the brain
goes into a final end point
called the hypothalamus,
which releases a special hormone
that then turns on a cascade
of other hormones in our body,
circulates in the blood,
turns on a stress hormone
in the end called cortisol in the humans.
And cortisol is a chemical
then that goes around all over the body,
goes back to our brain
and says, do something.
And sometimes the
information is to alert you
to pay attention, to act,
to run away or to focus
or to fight, that's the
fight and flight response,
and then eventually is to
say, stop worrying it's over.
So, it's a very dynamic response
that encodes the information
in a biological way
and both encodes the
beginning and the end of it.
And it's a system that you
find in a dog, in a cat,
in a mouse, in a rat, in
a human, you know, monkey.
It's very nicely conserved.
- Thank you, Dr. Akil.
So we're going to zoom out
a little from the brain
to all of society.
And I'd just love to understand Dr. Kohrt
how you define stress from a
behavior science perspective.
So for instance I've seen that, you know,
there's lots of articles lately
about being more mindful,
practicing yoga, you know, sort of staying
in the moment as an individual,
but your work really
suggests the importance
of community to building resilience,
and I was hoping you could explain that.
- Yeah, I would be delighted
to, and I thank you so
much Sujata and Laura
for the opportunity to be here
and happy 100th anniversary
to Science News.
So, concepts of stress and resilience
are often thought of in
terms of the individual,
that something is happening
to me I am stressed out.
And I think throughout the pandemic
we've all heard these
messages of self-care,
take care of yourself, do some meditation,
do some exercise, try to eat right.
So the idea of it's kind of,
this is an internal thing
happening to me, and then I'm
supposed to respond to it.
I think of my, the own--
the hospital where I work
and they gave us all free
access to mindfulness apps
throughout the pandemic which is great.
But as an anthropologist,
I also think about stress
and resilience as part of systems.
They're part of families,
part of communities,
part of societies, part of nations.
If we think ourselves in kind
of an interconnected web,
then that stress that's on the system
is also going to affect me.
But in terms of resilience,
it's really freeing to think
about that because the idea
is the system is resilient,
not just the individual.
I've done a lot of work as
a humanitarian practitioner
in disaster affected settings,
after an earthquake, after a civil war.
And what I've seen is
it's really the community
that determines how
people respond to stress
rather than any one individual.
I really loved the comment
that Huda made about you know,
our brains telling us the trauma is over,
the stress is over to stop freaking out.
And that's something that occurs,
not only internally with regard
to our endocrine regulation in our brains,
but we rely on our friends on
our family, on our coworkers
to say the same thing to us.
Hey, they know you're through this,
you've made it through that, you're able
to take care of yourself.
So resilience is constantly something
that we're doing inside and
with everybody else around us
at the same time.
Which is why I think it's so important
to talk about it right now,
because we're in the midst of
a pandemic where in many ways
we've been cut off from those
social connections around us
that help us respond to
stress and be resilient.
- Fascinating.
- Yeah, that idea,
of kind of looking at
this at different levels,
you know, you can go all
the way into the cortisol
released in a certain brain area,
you could zoom out to
the person and the body,
and then you can zoom out
to the societal effects
and how we're all interconnected, it's,
I'm curious how you two see
those levels interacting,
you know, is there discoveries
to be had at all the levels?
Are they interconnected?
How do you see them kind
of working together?
- So, if I may,
the question is what is stressful?
Let's think about humans
in particular for a minute.
And I remember when I first started,
I would try to do things
to human subjects,
including putting them in a cold room
or asking them math questions.
And one day my assistant said, you know,
"The people who give us a
biological stress response
are doing it, especially if
they think we're judging them
about how they're doing
on their math questions,
not so much how hard the math problem is."
And sort of the penny drop that they,
that a lot of it is social.
That being judged for example,
is really biologically what's
triggering the stress system.
And then we started doing
studies in animals as well.
And we realized how
much social interaction
is a key component of the stress system.
So if you think about the
job of surviving altogether,
exactly what Brendan said
is absolutely critical.
You're not alone in the world,
whether you're in the wild
or in a modern society,
and you need to take
care of whether yourself
or your babies or your property,
you need to take the
environment into consideration
and that includes the social environment.
So, social encoding is absolutely key
to, we have entire brain
systems, brain circuits
that encode relationships,
support, hierarchy,
aggression, social interactions.
So these ideas are completely compatible
because the social setting and the biology
are all part of that same
survival evolutionary framework
that we're all living in.
- I mean, it seems really intuitive.
But, I think it's easy to
forget that we're social beings.
And I'm curious Dr. Kohrt,
when we spoke earlier
you mentioned that, you know,
the sort of therapist client,
your psychiatrist and the
therapist client relationship
is very individual.
And I'm just wondering how you began
to look at this as more
of a social question,
stress and resilience as
more of a social question.
- As a psychiatrist going
through years of training
to become a good therapist,
we always think about the relationship
of that person who's
going through distress,
sitting in a room with me together
and how we talked about problems.
And you get trained a lot on those skills,
and then being able to
teach an individual skills
to help respond to the
distress in their lives.
And so for most of my clinical training,
that was how I thought about the idea
of kind of healing and recovery.
But in terms of my anthropological work
in different places around the world,
I can remember at this point
almost 25 years ago exactly.
It was my first trip to Southern Nepal
to see how people with mental illness
dealt with the suffering and recovered.
And there I saw a small
temple built in the community.
There were no psychiatrists,
no psychologists available,
and people who were in distress,
some that we might diagnose
with depression, some with PTSD,
even some with more severe conditions
like mania and bipolar disorder,
I saw them come to this
temple and spend time together
to go through rituals together
to heal and process this .
Family members would also come
from time to time to support them.
And although by no means did
it kind of cure everything,
it was really incredible to
see in the absence of even,
you know, most medications
and the supports that way,
there were still ways to support people
and help them heal together.
And I've seen since then
really great combinations
of when you have medicines available,
but you also have these
great community supports
that get mobilized.
Conversely, I've seen the reverse happen.
In my experience working
with child soldiers,
what was surprising to me
is even though many of them
had gone through absolutely, you know,
awful traumatic events, not
all of them really did poorly.
Some of them came back
to their communities
and they did really quite well
after such awful things happening to them,
but other child soldiers we
saw in Nepal came back home,
and really suffered
from chronic debilitating
post-traumatic stress disorder
and other forms of psychological ailments.
And the difference wasn't the trauma.
It was how the families,
schools, teachers, communities,
religious leaders responded
to those child soldiers
as they came back home.
What we saw in the one
communities where they did well
was lots of support,
welcoming them back to school,
help them restart their lives,
and in other community
where there was not support
for them coming back,
former child soldiers
who were girls were
forced to sit on the floor
in the classroom, some
weren't even allowed
back in the schools.
And what we saw was that it was actually
the social ostracization being excluded
from returning to society that
really made the difference
in terms of trauma leading
to psychological distress.
And it really interesting
kind of a historical fact
is that, although we all talk
about PTSD all the time now,
the PTSD as a diagnosis
really didn't exist
before the Vietnam war.
It wasn't until around 1980,
when psychiatrists in
their typical manuals
included PTSD in large
part based on research done
with people returning from Vietnam,
where you had the same process in the US,
some people came back to communities,
got a lot of support from
their families and communities,
but in other places around the US
when people came back home as soldiers,
they were shunned by communities,
they were not allowed to return,
they were mocked politically.
And really it's that experience,
that social response after trauma,
that really makes an
important determination
of whether trauma leads to distress,
or trauma can be something
that we recover from and are resilient to.
- It's a really
interesting idea, you know,
you bring up not just the
original traumatic experience,
but the response afterward,
and kind of this really
crucial time element.
And I wonder Dr. Akil,
you've written this
really nice perspective
on the kind of the history of
discovering the stress system
and kind of how these concepts
have changed over time.
So I'm wondering if you could tell us
a little bit about that progression
of our understanding of it.
You know, it's not just a simple fight
or flight discreet event,
but it seems rather
to be this more kind of
interactive, adaptive concept.
- So, if you step back and think about
what the job is of the brain in general,
you know, especially as you get
to more complicated organisms
like mammals, humans.
The job is to recognize the environment,
cope with it,
get the best out of it,
avoid the worst out of it.
So it is really about
perceiving, remembering, assessing,
responding, learning
so that you can evolve
and even predicting what's
going to happen in the future
so you avoid the pain and agony.
That job sits really at the
interface between the individual
and the world around it.
And that's the physical world,
that's the social world.
The stress system is exactly that system.
It's not genes alone, it's
not environment alone,
it's a system that
assesses the environment.
And through evolution, we
have multiple mechanisms
of how to cope.
Some of them are actually defensive.
It's, you know, where
you just go in a corner
and hide from threat, for example.
And some are more, you know, exploratory,
like you are willing to take a
risk because it might be fun,
or it might be something
productive out there.
And in a population, there
is a distribution of people.
Some tend to be more conservative
in the way they interact with the world,
and some might be more
extroverted, interactive,
risk-taking and so on.
And there is no right and wrong.
It's good for the population at large,
to have different kinds of reactions
to the world of interacting
with each other.
But if the point of this whole thing
is to be constantly
assessing the environment,
then we can't think of it
only as an alarm system.
It's not just your alarm
that's sitting there doing
nothing until a horrible,
like the fire, you know,
there's a fire, or, you know,
an attack, it has to be monitoring
and adapting constantly.
And so, I think, and we see
that even the level of monitoring changes
during the course of the day for example,
and in different settings.
So it's a very much alive, ongoing system
that does good things
as well as bad things.
And the good things are this
kind of very adaptive plastic
malleable way of learning.
And the more complicated the creature,
the more actually noise
there is in the system,
because the more
unpredictable the environment
and the richer the opportunities are.
Whereas if you are ultra programmed
like a monarch butterfly,
it's beautifully programmed
way better than we are,
but then the environment
can vary by much.
So you build all this kind of elasticity,
plasticity, adaptability into the system.
But the price for that
is it's never perfect.
It's always kind of trying to catch up
with what is going on.
It can do that for short
periods really well,
and that's what we call good stress.
Where something happens,
you learn from it,
you get a swift stress response,
it makes you pay attention,
it makes you remember,
it makes you change your
behavior, and respond accordingly.
But if it keeps going and going and going,
and there is no relief
either within yourself
or through your support system,
then it's cumulative and
the cost is biological
and very expensive and literally changes
the fabric of the brain.
And so, again, very highly intertwined
with what the environment is doing,
and time is really important.
So your point about time,
the points that have been made about time.
The sequence of events,
the duration of the event,
the direction that they're
going, are they cumulative?
Are they letting off at times?
Are you having time
to integrate the
information and restart it?
All of that can be seen
both psychologically,
and we know some biological
correlates for it.
- Yeah, as you were saying,
stress that goes on and on, I
had thoughts of the pandemic,
and we've all experienced
this for a long, long time.
- That's right.
- And I know both of you
have worked with animals.
And I'd be curious if you could, you know,
compare what you know from
laboratory studies, you know,
what things do you do to the animals
to elicit a stress response,
and how might that compare
with what we're all experiencing now?
You know, you've already
touched on the isolation,
the long duration, the uncertainty
about future, you know,
are there parallels you can tell us about?
- Brendan you want to
start and then I'll follow?
- Sure, so my direct animal
research days are long behind me
I deal with the bipedal
human animals these days.
But the animal research
has really been incredible
to inform how we think about this.
And I really take kind
of a biocultural evolutionary perspective.
So the idea of what we're
trying to understand
about stress resilience and healing,
we can look across evolution
not just our biological evolution,
but also how cultures have evolved.
And if we think about
evolutionary processes,
evolutions doesn't just act on individuals
it acts on groups.
So we can actually see
that in, especially in social mammals,
the evolution of these social behaviors
to respond to stress.
If we think about kind of healing,
one of the best images that
comes to mind are, you know,
the images that Jane Goodall described
working with chimpanzees
of grooming behaviors.
That if you look at somebody
distressed in a group,
a distressed, you know, adolescent
or a distressed female
partner or male partner,
that often it's through grooming,
that people would calm down,
that it would, that would,
or the chimpanzees would calm down.
That was the behavior that
formed an alliance again,
they got a chimpanzee who is distressed
to calm and be able to interact.
And if we look at this, it really
is a behavior that can be seen
across almost all social
mammals in some way.
A really interesting thing
is that in the 1990s,
there was a group of Dutch researchers,
and they were working
on creating, you know,
rat models of PTSD.
And so they would put a rat in a cage
with a quite aggressive larger male rat,
and then have the rat go
back to its original cage,
and then look and see
if it had a lot of the behaviors of PTSD.
And what they found
was that when they were trying
to replicate this behavior
amongst rats, that they
weren't seeing it initially,
and they were saying, "Well,
why is that not the case?"
And what they noticed is typically
they were taking the rats
and then putting them back
with other rats with
whom they were familiar.
If they took the rat,
had that rat exposed to
that aggressive male rat,
and then put that rat back
alone, suddenly all those,
a lot of the behaviors
that we think of when we think of PTSD,
avoidance, hyper arousal to any stimuli,
and even the hypothalamic
pituitary adrenal stress response
that Huda was just describing,
that you can recreate all
of that in a rat model.
But it was particularly in
the rats who were caged alone
after a stressor that you
really saw this response.
The other thing is that we can
also think about the biology
of healing and how that's
kind of evolutionary
in our past and ourselves now.
That there's a whole process that happens
when we as a human being,
or again amongst amongst chimps or rats
or other social mammals,
when we see another member of our species
or our in group in
particular that's distressed,
we also feel that stress.
We have our own stress
response to others in distress.
When that happens, we use
our own internal mechanisms
to begin to calm ourselves down,
but because we're cued
to somebody else's stress
through mirror neurons
and other processes,
we then engage with them.
We reach out, we try to help.
And that actually by giving support,
not only does their stress reduce,
but there's actually a feedback loop
where we get the kind of that warm glow
that nice fuzzy feeling
from helping somebody else.
And that causes us to repeatedly engage
in that support of other people.
And that's really the flow
of empathy in our species
that helps us to realize
that we're not just
alone healing ourselves,
but we're responsible to be
healed, to heal other people,
but also should be
receptive to being healed
by others in our families,
communities, and social lives.
- Yeah, so, I want to
echo some of the things
that Brendan said.
One is that we have an
unpublished studies in animal
that shows that effect of community.
Not only on the kind of
isolation after the fact,
but even during a stressful event.
If we take animals that are
genetically have a tendency
to be very inhibited and very, you know,
passive and inhibited,
and we put them through an experience
that is negative for
them, it really matters
who else is in the room with them,
even if they're in separate
cages and pretty separated.
The same experience if they undergo it
during the experience itself alone,
versus in a group produces
very different brain patterns
and very different consequences.
We don't know how they're communicating,
through smell for example,
or through ultrasonic vocalization.
But we again discovered this by chance
because we had different studies
and they were giving us different results
and we tracked it down to the fact
that whether you're
experiencing the stress alone
or in a group makes a big difference.
It's not only whether also
you're supported afterwards,
but even during.
And it brings to mind what happens
if a whole group of people experiences
a traumatic event together,
versus if you're alone
when you experience it.
So even animals show us that.
I think it was very cool to discover
and we tracked down some
of the brain circuits
that get activated.
The other thing I wanted to touch on
is this idea of healing,
but also of stress and
resilience in general,
we've been saying those terms,
and who experiences stress and how.
And a lot of people might
think that being resilient
is not feeling stressed or
not feeling stressed as much.
And I think that's one kind of resilience.
And, but the other kind of resilience
is having counterregulatory mechanisms
to compensate for that stress
and rebalance yourself,
which I think I hear
Brendan kind of referring
to in a lot of these
cases, like, you know,
being in a group, feeling supported.
And we've been very interested
in understanding mechanisms
of stress versus resilience,
different mechanisms,
biological and psychological, behavioral,
both in animal models
and in human studies,
and in this case, these
are college freshmen.
And in both cases, it's very clear
that there are genetic
biological mechanisms
of resilience that we see
both in animals and in humans.
But that there are environmental
mechanisms of resilience
that are pretty clearly independent,
and that will more than compensate
for the genetic vulnerability.
So we have animals that
are very vulnerable
to negative emotions,
then we also have college
freshmen who genetically,
when you're looking at their genetic load,
look like they're going
to be very vulnerable.
And we've been studying
them through the pandemic,
before and through the pandemic
and looking at that interplay
between genes and environment
and depression, anxiety versus resilience.
And it's very evident
that you can be very
genetically vulnerable
and yet socially and
psychologically resilient.
And that there are people who seem
to be very biologically resilient,
and under normal circumstances
like before the pandemic,
they sail through a typical freshman year
without experiencing too much distress
or anxiety or depression,
but the pandemic actually
hit them really hard.
And it's as if they had not developed
some of the psychosocial tools
that people who are more
vulnerable might have developed
in order to survive.
And so this idea,
and we see that as I
said in animal models.
So there is this idea that
there are multiple paths
to achieving resilience,
as well as multiple ways to be vulnerable.
And genetics is not destiny,
and context really can
more than compensate.
And that even some
experience in being stressed
is actually resilience inducing
in a way that you don't see
if somebody never experienced distress
and then suddenly gets hit pretty hard.
- That's fascinating, I kind of remember
reading these articles
when the pandemic first hit
from people who suffered
from sort of extreme anxiety
saying, "I'm actually doing okay,
I've prepared for the worst."
So sort of related to that,
I feel like the pandemic
is almost short-circuiting
like these coping mechanisms
that we have, and that we are
fortunately able to develop.
And, you know, like you said, you know,
genetics isn't destiny,
but I'm thinking like social distancing,
this, and a lot of the
social science literature,
it's like the together apart.
And I just I'm wondering
how we can sort of apply
these, you know, sort of
more theoretical findings
to what we're seeing now
with sort of these ruptures
in society with the pandemic.
- Exactly Sujata so, and
Huda your points as well
in terms of how certain college students
responded to stressors before the pandemic
and how this has really changed
our ways of interacting
with others, you know,
and to the point of people with, you know,
anxiety and how might
they have responded before
in some ways it's almost,
the pandemic was protective in some ways
because they didn't have a
lot of those interactions.
So I think in some ways
actually being forced
to interact with others
and spend time with them
when you think about colleges, you know,
college students on a campus
or us in our daily lives,
dropping kids off at
school and picking them up,
they're all these little
micro interactions
that are just reassuring
back to Huda's point
about, you know, the experience
of a traumatic event.
Are you alone, or are you
going through it with others?
And so I think the way
that society was built
prior to the pandemic,
we went through a lot of things together.
And in many ways now
we've been having to go
through things alone.
So the question is, how do we find ways
to be able to do that?
It doesn't necessarily force us
into a distressful situation,
but helps us feel not so isolated.
And in my work really it's about
kind of the flow of empathy
and how do we promote the flow of empathy
during especially a humanitarian disaster
like a global pandemic.
So two things have come
up in our work recently
that have been really important.
So one, is the recognition
that particular individuals
have really been isolated
from accessing mental health
care throughout the pandemic,
especially communities, BIPOC communities,
so black and brown
communities, indigenous,
and other peoples of color.
That in many ways those individuals
had to access, you know,
things in person, there was a loss
of that, and then having to
shift over to remoteness.
But then the other piece was
it has been a recognition
in the past year that
we have a huge disparity
into who actually provides
mental health services.
That the US is 40% minorities,
but only one out of every
10 mental health specialists
is not white.
And so how can we have people
that have shared lived experience
come from shared
communities, shared cultures,
when our mental health professionals
do not represent the makeup
of the American public.
So we've tried to find
ways to actually shift
how mental health care is delivered,
and shift who's delivering
mental health care.
So we've taken interventions
that we've used
after an earthquake in Nepal,
or after a war in other setting,
and adapted those actually
for use in New York City,
and training up people who work
in community-based
organizations, religious centers,
other types of community-based bodies
to be able to provide brief
psychological support,
so you have someone from
the same community as you
able to support you.
And we know that that really promotes
that flow of empathy, understanding.
Back to Huda's point, it's
like we are in this together
going through these difficult situations.
It's not a substitute for when
a specialist might be needed
or something like
medication might be needed,
but it's really important
for that general level
of psychological distress
that has just escalated
for all of us.
But another really important piece
about trying to make sure
that there's more care
and more empathy in the world,
is also about our divisions in society
and stigma and discrimination.
That if you look at people who are seen
as not part of your group,
and when they go for it through suffering,
you don't have that same response
of kind of internalizing their suffering
and reaching out to help them.
There's this, you know,
German term schadenfreude
which is, you know,
actually even neurobiology,
neurobiologically rather true concept
where you can feel pleasure when somebody
who's not in your social
group is in pain, right?
That's something about our
evolution made that adaptive.
Which means we need to find ways
to break down those group divisions.
And so we've done a lot
of work on this in Nepal,
we're now doing it in seven
countries around the world
where in particular we're
trying to reduce the stigma
and discrimination
related to mental illness.
So we teach people living
with mental illness
to tell their stories, to use photographs
or video or voice narratives,
to be able to share what it's like
and what they're going through.
And then we play these,
or have these individuals
come and give talks
to healthcare workers
who often are stigmatizing against them,
and they begin to find those connections,
that idea that our lives
really aren't so far apart.
You have the same concerns
about your kids, that I do,
you have your same,
you enjoy the same festivals
and holidays that I do,
but trying to find those connections.
And when you create those connections,
that empathy flow opens up.
So suddenly I feel your suffering
and I want to respond in a
positive way to support you.
So I think the two really important things
that we're recognizing as
a society now is that one,
we need to have a broader,
much more diverse mental health workforce
to really represent the whole array
of different forms of
human, of lived experience
amongst us as a nation and as a society.
And the second is what tools can we use
to break down barriers of
stigma and discrimination
so that people are more empathetic,
caring and helpful towards one another,
especially when coming out of a, you know,
two year long potentially
longer pandemic at this point.
- So, I want to also add something
that I've been thinking about, which is
I find very unusualabout this pandemic.
We talk about isolation which
is of course the big stress
of loneliness, isolation, and so on.
But to me, an important question,
and I wonder how we will
be able to deal with it
is how we perceive
ourselves and each other
in terms of rules.
For example, I am a grandmother and I,
before the pandemic took
some plan, and you know,
I work full time, I'm very busy,
but I also took pleasure in
helping with my grandchildren
both to connect with them,
but also to take some
of the load of the back
of my, you know, son and
daughter in law who live in town.
During the pandemic, not allowed, right?
You can't play that role.
So, not only are parents of children
overburdened because their
kids are at home, or, you know,
being sent home because
of somebody getting sick,
but people in the community
who used to be able to
help them, can't help them.
So that cuts both ways actually, right?
It cuts both because I feel helpless,
and they want to protect
me, but the whole nature
of who is capable of
giving empathy has changed.
And who you perceive as a
potential threat to you,
like a friend who comes too close to you
is, can be, if they're not
vaccinated, or if you have,
if you know somebody who
is immune compromised,
all of these nuances of our
social fabric have changed.
So it's not just isolation,
it's how we're labeling each
other as sources of anxiety,
as source of, people we need to protect
versus people who can be helpful.
So, rules have changed.
And I think it's important to recognize
that and we empower some people,
and we support other
people who are feeling
like their whole entire support system
had to be lost because they're
protecting somebody else.
So, I don't know that we have
thought this through fully
as a society, but it's actually quite,
pervasive
and I think very problematic
at multiple levels.
- Yeah, you raise a great point.
I know all of us have probably gone
through those kinds of re-evaluations
of these are my children,
but they're also unvaccinated threats
to my parents right now.
You know, they're, how do I assess
all of these various risks
and reevaluate how I see these people
who have been such a profound
part of our fabric, you know.
- And so.
- It changes it.
- For me one reason I want to surface
this is it doesn't need
to get all the way.
So definitely the rates of depression
and anxiety and et cetera are going up
and we need to deal with those.
But I also run a lab up
with a lot of young people,
young women who have children,
and I see what, how demanding
that is, and I watch
my own children with
their children and so on.
And how do we socially support them
and also re-empower other people
who used to play roles and no longer can.
And I think it would be really good for us
to start re-engaging in how we can
create new roles or we
reformulate the roles
that we have in order to
evolve that social network
that has been completely upset.
- One thing, we've
touched on a little bit,
but I would love more thoughts on,
this idea of kind of cultivating control,
cultivating something that
you derive pleasure from,
that you feel competent at,
that you're good at, that you enjoy.
How does that fit in with
this idea of resiliency,
and how important is that as a concept
to kind of the human psyche
or even our neurobiology?
You know, what does that do to our brain
to have something like that,
that we feel good about?
- Yeah, I really liked
the point about Brendan,
the flow of empathy as a positive force.
I find that in neuroscience
and in psychiatry,
we think more about the bad things
and not enough about the good things.
That's not a scientific term, but like,
you know, we think about
depression and anxiety
and stress and addiction and so on,
and we try to take people
from a negative state
to like a neutral state, and say,
let's see if we can get rid of the anxiety
or decrease your depression
or minimize your stress,
but sometimes that's not possible.
And so I have this concept that
I call it emotional algebra,
where you can, if you have negative,
you just need to counterbalance
it with something positive.
And, you know, the negative could be huge
and the positives that have to be small,
but many, maybe many of
them, many tiny positives,
sometimes a big positive,
but if you can't afford,
so, but if you think that
you have a certain capital
of emotionality, and it's
trending in a very negative way,
because of circumstances,
why not try to put
something into your account?
That's more on the positive side.
And that requires some paying
attention to the things,
stopping long enough to pay attention
to the things that give you
a little bit of pleasure,
a little bit of joy.
And they can be about you,
they can be about people around you.
So for example I was
telling you, it's been hard
not to be able to help family.
So, I try and give more donation
to people who are, you know, in need.
You know, since, you
know, we were quarantined
and people wanted older people
to be especially careful and so on.
Well, what else can you deploy?
So different people have different skills
that they can deploy or
different resources or whatever.
So, finding things that bring you joy,
even if nobody knows
you're the one who did it,
but they bring you joy.
That I think really important
to our mental health
and especially important
in times of high stress.
And it could be cooking a good meal
and, you know, giving
some to the neighbor,
and it could be making
a flower arrangement
or enjoying the change of
colors or doing a good deed,
saying something positive
to somebody on Twitter.
Any of that, it's all good.
(all chuckles)
- Does that happen?
- Nobody does that.
(all chuckles)
- I was just going to echo that.
And also the part of, I think,
Huda what you're bringing up.
And it's also something that we,
I think as a field in mental
health I have had to rethink
are these ideas that the thought
has to precede the action
or that the feeling has
to proceed the action,
often is hesitation of, well,
I'm not going to reach out
to somebody until I feel like I'm okay.
Or I'm not going to go
engage in this behavior
or support someone else or do
something with someone else
until I feel like I'm doing better.
Or even things that, you
know, brought you joy before,
this hesitation to engage in those
because like, oh, I'm not feeling it yet.
An increasing realization that actually
it's starting these both behaviors,
engaging in those behaviors,
especially when they involve other people,
that the positive
emotion at that wellbeing
comes from the process
of doing that rather than proceeding it.
And just as I talked about
all that empathy loop
it's really after you've helped somebody
that that response occurs.
So finding opportunities
just as Huda is saying
with that emotional algebra
to be able to do things to help others
that give you some type of
reward, rather than saying,
"Well, I'm going to get
rid of my negatives first
and then I can go out
and do positive things."
Throughout the pandemic
and a recognition of actually
throughout our lives,
a lot of those negative things
are there, and we are not just the sum
of those negative things,
we are all of those other
positive things as well.
And if, you know, my work with
people surviving with PTSD
from humanitarian conflict,
soldiers has taught me anything,
in many ways it's not the focus
of take my PTSD symptoms away.
That's not the goal,
the goal is I want to be
able to help my family,
I want to be able to interact
with those around me.
If you can give me those
tools, some of those symptoms,
some of that distress, that's okay,
but I want to be able to make
a contribution in some way.
So I think encouraging others around us
to make those contributions,
and it goes back to one of
the points that I made earlier
is part of our role is not
just reaching, you know,
reaching out to others to help them,
but also asking for help when we need it.
Every time we do that
and tell somebody else
that we're in distress,
we're worried, we're upset,
we're having a hard time,
we're giving somebody else an opportunity
to engage in that empathetic interaction,
and that they feel better as well.
So that actually asking for help
is a sign of impr--,
is an opportunity to improve
things for everybody,
not just for yourself.
- I think that makes a lot of sense.
I feel like I'm going to keep
an emotional algebra chart
on our (Huda giggles).
Family wall (laughs).
- Yeah, no I think I find
using economic economic terms
for affect regulation to be useful
like do I want to invest
that much negative energy?
Is this worth it?
Is this, like, you know,
it's an investment.
All of this is we only have
so many resources within us.
How do you want to distribute them?
How do you want to use them?
How do you want to, and that's the part
that is more personal,
but can be reinforced,
can be learned together.
And that, you know, that,
I mean, the one thing
I want to say is building
resilience is a lifelong process,
you're not born with it,
and you learn from having
developed some how to do more,
but you also learn from watching others,
they teach you how they survive.
And so, sharing those
tools are really important.
And then the other point
about whether it's top down or bottom up
is really important.
In Western cultures we're very used
to say thinking that everything comes
from, to use biological term
the frontal cortex from thought,
and then thought must lead
to action and to feelings.
But if you do any exercise,
any yoga, any meditation,
any breathing, you understand
that there is a lot
that's biological that bubbles up
and changes the state of your mind.
And there is also a biology
to that, a very strong biology
to that, and that in turn
reinterprets a lot of things.
So we haven't said very
much about exercise,
but definitely, definitely,
and sleeping right, and eating right,
and you know, everything
that your mother told you,
but it really does matter,
especially in times of stress.
- It reminds me too of Dr. Kohrt's point
about the grooming and the
importance of touch, you know,
these sensory experiences
that then can calm our bodies
and our brains.
- Absolutely.
- And yeah, it seems like
there are just so many
kind of sensory things
we might think about too.
- That's, also some
people, for some people
that's really important for that reason.
So, yeah, I think it, I mean,
it's been a terrible, terrible
time and so many lives lost
and so many people suffering,
we will take us a long time to figure out,
and the pandemic of mental
health is just as huge.
But I also think it might
be a teachable moment
for us as humans, as modern
humans about what matters most.
You know, and how to bring
together our understanding
from the most biological to
the most social and integrative
and even philosophical.
If we do it right, we
would learn something
and we'll come out of it maybe
doing better for each other.
- You know, earlier you
talked about this idea
of kind of experiencing stressful events
might buffer you in the future,
it might teach you how to handle it,
it might kind of spark a
little more resilience.
Will we all be better off
in five years in 10 years?
You know, has this experience
kind of inoculated us in some way?
Is there a silver lining there?
- No, this is where I go back
to individual differences
and how different people
are in different settings
and different conditions.
For some people, it will
have toughen them up.
And when they encounter
something, they say,
"Hey, you know, I know I've
fended for myself before,
I can manage it, I know I can survive."
For others, it might put them
really close to the edge,
and it won't take very
much for them to fall off,
or they have fallen off the edge.
And because we all start
in different places,
and we perceive stress differently,
and we have these different
modules within us,
some of them biologically programmed,
and some of them through
development and through experience,
and how this has hit different
people has been different.
So, even though in neuroscience,
we try to understand the
brain, the circuitry,
I am somebody who really
cares about differences,
and I think that we need
to be very respectful
and some people will get
over it and, you know,
thrive for it, and other people
will need a lot of support.
- And I was just going to echo
that there is so much diversity.
And I hope that as we come out
of this and lessons learned
that we'll also have
more diversity of ways
that we heal ourselves and
take care of ourselves.
You know, I think prior to the pandemic,
being able to do therapy remotely
was kind of considered taboo
and you had to be in the same room.
That hugely limits who has
access to care in some way.
At the same time I think
another aspect of the pandemic
has been in how we all
think about mental health.
I think there was already beginning
to be a generational
shift with younger people
being more open to discuss it,
but for anybody to come
out of this pandemic
and not be able to say, you know,
"I experienced some symptoms
of anxiety or depression
or even trauma in myself,"
I think would not be very
insightful or reflective.
So hopefully we're also going
to be continually opening up the doors
to more honest and frank discussions
about how we're all doing,
how we're all feeling
and the supports we need.
And I think the other area where I hope
we really come out of this
pandemic in a changed way
is a more diverse,
comprehensive care system
that is going to think
about every American
and every person around the world
in a more holistic way showing,
because the pandemic has shown us
how interconnected we all really are.
And I think, you know, the
other thing is the realization
that certain things that have been taboo
in mental health care like touch,
oh no you would never touch anybody
that's not related at all,
just as Huda is saying
and Laura you brought up like,
that's part of our biology.
So how do we get things like touch
to be part of our healing process?
Because we aren't just, you
know, free floating minds,
we all have bodies and the
bodies are big determinant
about how we're doing psychologically.
So I hope these types of
changes and realizations
will lead to a different way
that we interact with others
and heal others going forward.
- And the one thing I
want to add is thinking
more about children and development
in adolescents, I think,
you know, they're not just
little adults as we know,
and I have no idea how some
of this is being processed
by them and how it's
all been impacting them.
But I hope we have more
resources for mental health
in children and adolescents,
and that we learn how to do
better, how to support them,
and I am really concerned
about how this is going to play out.
I think that they deserve
special attention.
- And I'll just make one final point
on that and kind of hope
for that next generation.
As I also think in kids,
that's when empathy, you know,
begins to be in full bloom,
and it's really about cultivating
that and using that in
their lives going forward.
It's sadly something probably
we spend a lot more time
restricting our empathy as we get older,
rather than helping it grow,
and I think about one
moment during the, you know,
a couple of months
early into the pandemic,
kids are all at home, I had a, you know,
I have a four year old daughter,
my wife and I were arguing as one does
when you're home with lots of little kids
in the middle of the pandemic,
and four-year old who
had learned at school
some deep breathing and
mindfulness exercises
had this little pinwheel
that she would blow into
whenever she was upset.
The teachers had taught her to do that.
And as we were having our
little bit heated discussion,
she walks over with the
pinwheel and holds it up.
So she could already see
in us, we were distressed,
we needed some time and she
was there to help heal us.
So, we got to take care of our kids,
and we also need to listen and acknowledge
when they're telling us what's going on,
because they might be the best messengers
for us to be a better society,
be a group that really
cares about one another.
- I agree, I'm so impressed
with so many of them
who have been like,
thinking about wearing masks
because it protects other people,
or doing things like learning in a way
that no matter how much
you say it in words
when it didn't have consequences,
it kind of, you know goes past,
but that I think, you know, especially in
Western culture,
especially if the kid happens to be lucky
in a family that is not, you
know, living a distressed life,
they did not have a realistic view
of what the world goes through.
But now I think they have a better idea.
Because this is how,
what we're going through
and complaining about.
I mean, I'm from Syria and
I watched civil war go on
and those people live
through that and you realize
the world suffers on a regular basis
and having an empathy towards
that is not a bad thing
as long as we can maintain also equanimity
in mental health through it if possible.
- That's a really beautiful sentiment.
I think so much emphasis has
been on like lost academics.
And I think we forget sometimes
that there's this whole
emotional piece and empathy piece
that maybe they've gained something too.
I don't know, as a parent
myself, that's a nice reminder.
So I think that is it from us.
Is there anything either of you want to,
you know, wrap up with?
- Well, I wanted to thank you and say,
I really appreciated the opportunity,
I liked the fact that it
went from biology to society,
happy 100th anniversary, and, you know,
I hope this reaches some people
and helps them in some way.
- And thank you so much
for this opportunity.
It was great Laura and Sujata
to have this opportunity
to answer questions and
Huda great hearing from you,
and I think we have our
next global mission together
to have the bio-psycho-social
frame of resilience
for the post pandemic world.
So thank you so much for this opportunity.
- Well, if we've set up a
collaboration, great (chuckles).
This was fascinating,
I think it was really, really interesting
to put together the
brain and behavior piece,
Laura and I don't always
get to work together.
So that was kind of fun too.
So thank you so much for joining us.
And for our viewers, you can learn more
about both Dr. Kohrt and Dr. Akil's work,
and keep up with their latest discoveries
in behavioral science and neuroscience
by visiting us at sciencenews.org
and connecting with us on social media.
Thanks so much for joining us.
(bright upbeat music)